[Music]
so the multiverse is a really
interesting extension of what we call
inflation theory so right after the Big
Bang the majority of theories about how
our universe was formed requires of a
rapid period of inflation in the very
very early universe and there are many
many different models for how this very
rapid of inflation could have occurred
but the majority of these models are
called chaotic inflation Theory models
and they predict that not just one
universe would be created that multiple
universes would be created and this
lends itself to the idea of there being
a multiverse you can kind of I like to
imagine blowing bubbles and they're just
being lots of bubbles of different
shapes and different sizes around that's
kind of your this this idea of there
being multiple universes in in space
when I first started thinking about the
multiverse I really didn't like it
because I thought this isn't a theory I
can test because I can't see anything
outside my own observable universe and I
think I said at the at the start there's
no point in coming up with a theory if
you can't test it and but actually we
can test these theories of inflation so
if we can we can test theories and if
they make a prediction that our
multiverse is the consequence of that
theory then that's a great way of
actually testing this idea of there
being multiple universes out there so we
can test these inflation theories in the
very early universe when the universe
experienced this period of rapid
inflation that would imprint
gravitational waves so it's something
incredibly powerful event that you
should still be able to see the ripples
of now in in gravitational waves now
there's been the first detection of
gravitational waves recently this is not
my area of work it's absolutely
phenomenal what these scientists have
managed to do and so it's just giving
them time now to improve their
instrumentation their technology so we
can get down to the sort of
where we'll be able to see the remnants
of this rapid period of inflation and
then you can really test these models
are these chaotic inflation models the
way to go
does that really infer that there are
multiple universes out there and so what
would be your next research project my
next research project exciting it's
called the large synoptic survey
telescope it is a 10 meter telescope in
mountaintop in Chile in the Atacama
Desert it is one of the driest places in
the world if you ever go there you're
like constantly putting Vaseline on your
lips it's so dry and that's because you
want your telescope to always be able to
see the heavens so there's you're either
above the clouds or there are no clouds
to be had
it's the most amazing sight and when
you're there if you go out at night and
let your eyes get dark adapted it takes
about 10 minutes and when you look up at
the night sky it's bright it's the
funniest thing because everywhere you
look there are stars because it's just
that clear in that dark and if you let
your eyes adapt you can just see stars
everywhere it's most amazing sight now
this telescope is going to be surveying
the universe but for 10 years it's going
to do nothing else just take image the
sky image the sky do it again and again
and again and you build up that really
deep image so we're going to be looking
back to the universe only a couple of
billion years after the Big Bang we're
gonna be able to look that far back also
this technique of just looking again and
again night off tonight we're also gonna
be able to see things that move so we're
gonna find the killer asteroids that
might one day obliterate planet Earth
got that covered
oh that's not my research area but I'm
I'm happy that we've got that covered
and what I'll be doing this a-to-z
because it's so deep we'll be able to
use those techniques I was talking about
to map out the Dark Matter we're going
to be able to see how that dark matter
is changing and evolving the times we
can confront these different dark energy
theories I'm gonna combine it in with
other data of how galaxies are moving in
these environments so we can also test
gravity theories it's going to be an
exquisite dataset so they watch out for
that over the next 10 years as it builds
up its data and this amazing image of
the universe
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you